chadwick boseman was an inspiration to
many and as it turns out he spent his
final days working to improve the lives
of others
shock waves rippled throughout the
entertainment industry and the world on
august 28
2020 when bozeman's family revealed that
the black panther star had lost a four
year long battle with colon cancer at
the age of 43
keeping his diagnosis completely private
from the public and many of his
collaborators was a personal act of
courage
and the fact that boseman made many of
his most important and impactful films
while struggling with his illness
makes the physical feats involved in
them simply unbelievable
directors like ryan coogler who helmed
the first stand-alone film for bozeman's
king t'challa
have admitted in the days since
bozeman's passing that not even they
knew about the star's cancer diagnosis
which progressed from stage three to
stage four
in the four years between his diagnosis
and death with that in mind
every interaction between bozeman and
his friends and family is now seen in
the light of his own illness
including a text sent to one of black
panther's executive producers
this final exchange with one of his
colleagues tells fans
even more about what a considerate and
kind person bozeman was
right up until the very end this welcome
is one of the most amazing things i've
ever experienced
as nate moore one of the executive
producers on black panther told people
he and bozeman shared some touching
final words shortly before the actor
passed away
together the two partnered with the
make-a-wish foundation to help provide
comfort and joy to children diagnosed
with terminal illnesses
moore told the magazine it was during
lockdown and we worked together to get a
young boy a voice note from t'challa
as well as a package of toys no easy
feat when we weren't allowed to leave
our homes or go to the office but chad
figured out how to make it work because
he cared so intently and in hindsight so
personally
moore then told people exactly what
bozeman's final text to him said
according to moore bozeman wrote it
broke me man but we need to do that for
them
people deserve abundant life special
moments they've been through hell
battling disease
if we were able to ease their suffering
and bring joy for a moment
and hopefully moments as he goes through
the bags then we made a difference in
his life
moore added after sharing the text
message with people again
hindsight will tell us that chad felt
that way because he too
was battling a disease but i don't think
that's true
i think that's just who he was as a man
a leader and a caregiver first
who accomplished both of those things as
a performer and as a regular person
moore added that bozeman was
intimidating but in a good way
much has been said about his presence
when he walked into a room i'd argue
that the intensity of his gaze was also
unparalleled
because as intense as his gaze was his
smile could light up the sky
collaborators like coogler have also
shared their memories of bozeman
all while marveling at the strength it
must have taken to keep his diagnosis a
secret
as coogler told the hollywood reporter
in an incredibly emotional statement
because he was a caretaker a leader and
a man of faith
dignity and pride he shielded his
collaborators from his suffering
he lived a beautiful life and he made
great art day after day
year after year that was who he was he
was an
epic firework display i will tell
stories about being there for some of
the brilliant sparks till the end of my
days
what an incredible mark he's left for us
meanwhile other friends are sharing the
last messages they ever received from
bozeman
josh gad who starred alongside bozeman
in the thurgood marshall biopic marshall
recently posted screenshots of a message
from bozeman encouraging gad to enjoy
life
spread love and appreciate everything
even rainy los angeles afternoons
losing bozeman is hard enough for his
fans but this talented star's death
which cut short an extraordinary career
is clearly having an enormous effect on
the people closest to him as well
our thoughts are with bozeman's friends
and family during this time of grief